- Hi, everyone.
It is an absolute pleasure
and delight and honor for me
to invite you all to this
evening's wonderful lecture
as part of our Distinguished
Speaker Series.
And our speaker today is
Professor Susan Hockfield
whom many of you from the
Yale community might remember.
And she will be talking
to us about her new book
titled "The Age of Living Machines:
How Biology Will Build the
Next Technology Revolution".
Before I turn over to our dean
of faculty, Tamar Gendler,
to give a more formal
introduction to Susan,
I just wanted to share a few things.
First, I wanted to give
some bookkeeping notices
that I request you all to mute your audio
and your video because we
are recording the proceedings
and you will have an opportunity
to interact with Susan
and ask questions through the chat
and we'll keep the chat open
and we'll read out your questions to Susan
at the end of her talk.
So I also want, at this point,
to thank Richard and Barbara
Franke who are joining us
from warm and balmy Arizona
for their generosity and support
of the Franke Program
and Yale more, generally,
which allows us to do lots of innovative
across disciplinary programming.
And I think at this point,
the only thing I want to say
is that I have a personal
fond recollection of Susan
because by the time I joined
Yale as a junior faculty,
she was the provost and
it was just wonderful
to have someone warm and understanding
and absolutely brilliant and supportive
to be in the leadership.
So Tamar, I would like to
turn it over to you now
to formally introduce Susan.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you, Priya, thank you to the Frankes
who are here with us today.
Welcome, President Salovey
who is also present at
today's Franke Lecture.
I'm Tamar Gendler,
I'm dean of the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences here at Yale
and it is hard to think of somebody
who epitomizes the values
of the Franke Program
more completely than Susan Hockfield.
The Franke Program is
devoted to bringing together
multiple perspectives, in particular,
the humanities and the sciences
to think about the most profound questions
that the world brings to us.
And Susan Hockfield has made a career,
both intellectually and pragmatically
in her leadership as a
scholar and in her leadership
as an academic university citizen
of bringing together
things that other people
didn't notice the connections.
In some ways, this is no surprise.
After earning a BA in biology
from the University of Rochester
and a PhD from Georgetown
School of Medicine,
Susan Hockfield joined Yale in 1985
after a post at the Cold
Spring Harbor Laboratory
of James Watson.
Yes, that James Watson.
The Watson of Crick and Watson.
And this experience of having been present
at moments of origination,
present at moments of discovery,
present at moments
where unexpected insight
led to genuine change is
characteristic of her time
as an academic and as a university leader.
She joined Yale, as I said, in 1985.
She was tenured in 1991,
the same year I note that she was married
in our very own Battell Chapel
and became a full
professor three years later
in the Department of Neurobiology.
As a scholar, she excelled but perhaps,
even more striking was her capacity
for university leadership.
She was appointed dean of
Yale's Graduate School in 1998
and stayed in that role
for four years till 2002
when she took on the role as Yale provost.
And sadly, for us, but
happily for academia,
served in that role for two short years
before she was taken by our neighbor
to the North Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
where she served as a visionary
and transformative president
of MIT from 2004 to 2012.
As I've said already
what is characteristic
and distinctive and exciting
about Susan Hockfield's work
is the way in which it involves
bringing things together.
People, organizations, ideas.
At MIT, she had the
idea that one could use
as a locus of organization,
the convergence of engineering
and the life sciences
and through that insight,
brought the world things
like the David Koch Institute
For Integrative Cancer Research
and the Ragon Institute
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
Harvard University and
Mass General Hospital.
That is she broke down the boundaries
between the biological and
the engineering sciences.
She broke down the boundaries
between institutions in Cambridge.
between the private sector
and the public sector.
For example, catalyzing the development
of the Massachusetts Green High
Performance Computing Center
in Holyoke, which brought
together five universities,
two private companies and the
Commonwealth of Massachusetts.
Exemplary for our own
ambitions in planetary science
are the ways that she developed at MIT
on multidisciplinary institute-wide center
around energy which brought
the MIT Energy Initiative
to bring together individuals
from almost every academic
department at the university
to think about technologies and policies
for a sustainable energy future.
That practical ability
to bring things together
is combined with an intellectual ability
to bring things together,
which all of us are here
to hear evidence of and her new book,
"The Age of Living Machines",
which serves as a beautiful
background for her
and should serve as a beautiful background
for your own bedside
table in the coming weeks
is an extraordinary exploration
of how biology will build the
next technology revolution.
And with that introduction,
I suspect you have no
longer any interest at all
in hearing from anyone
but the extraordinary Susan Hockfield.
Welcome home.
We are thrilled to have you.
- Thank you so much, Priya and Tamar
for both the invitation and
both of your overly generous
and insightful introductions.
As Priya has just mentioned,
I have a long history at Yale
and immense fondness for
this great university
and for its people.
It is an indescribable privilege
to join one of Yale's great conversations
here in the Franke Program
in Science and Technology.
I offered very special thanks
and very special fondness
to Rich and Barbara Franke.
Great to see you who have
done so much for Yale
and who played such important roles
when Rick Levin recruited
me to his leadership team
as dean of the Yale Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences.
And, of course, you
all know that that team
came to include President Peter Salovey
and Rick's leadership team is well-known
for producing leaders, not just for Yale,
but for other institutions
and MIT did take advantage
of it in recruiting me.
But I have to say, I can
never thank Rick sufficiently
for changing the direction of my career.
I was on a path to understanding
how the brain assembles itself
over the course of human development.
He recruited me into a new
path that he had confidence
I would find as interesting
and as challenging
and that was to understand
how people can assemble
to accomplish more than anyone
can accomplish on their own,
which has been a great
challenge and great joy for me.
And for me, the thesis
of this lecture series
is central to how I think and
work as Tamar has described
and this is the
cross-disciplinary conversations
catalyze new insights, they
amplify ideas and their impact
and they're, just frankly, a
lot of fun to participate in.
That thesis of facilitating
cross-disciplinary conversations
is really the furniture
of the mind, if you will,
that was fostered during
my 20 years at Yale.
So with that short preamble,
I'm gonna start sharing my slides
so we can get started on today's topic.
Now, I have to say I'm gonna do this
with some little bit of
technological challenge but.
So, following the theme of
cross-disciplinary conversations,
today, I'm gonna share some thoughts
on our shared possible future.
I'm gonna talk about
today part of the story
that I've captured for general audiences.
This is important in my book.
The book is not for a
scientist or engineer,
it's for just plain old
people who wanna understand
what the future holds for us.
What is our very probable
technology future?
So, I, obviously, have
had the amazing privilege
of leading one of the
world's great universities
and as MIT's president,
MIT is just a little
bit of an unusual place,
but I had a breathtaking perspective
of the science and technology frontier.
It's a frontier of ideas, of discoveries,
of applications and much, much more.
On the future, I saw was,
frankly, astonishing.
And today, I'm gonna
share with you a glimpse
of that very probable technology future.
And I wanna say at the outset
that while I'm optimistic
about that future,
those of you who know me
knows that I tend to
be crazily optimistic,
I would say at this outset,
we have to all agree
that the future looks a bit bleak.
So today, I'm gonna share both my optimism
and also my caution
because, I think, both of them
really do need our attention.
So just to give you a sense
of some of the daunting
challenges that we face,
the planet's current population
of about 7 1/2 billion
people is projected to grow
to about 10 billion people by 2050.
And the demands of those 20 billion people
will be unprecedented.
And let me just call
out just a few of them.
We think about healthcare.
I mentioned here access,
accuracy and cost.
We spend, in the United
States, about 18% of GDP
on our healthcare provisions.
And while we do some amazing things,
frankly, we don't get good enough results
from that 18% of GDP.
We need to do better in many dimensions.
We need to be able to provide
high quality healthcare
to the poor and the rich alike.
Energy is a hugely challenging problem.
We already do not produce
the energy we need and use sustainably.
And it's pretty addicted that by 2050,
there will be a doubling of demand.
We simply have to figure out
how to provide the energy
that the world's population needs
without ruining the planet.
In terms of water and
food, we don't, today,
produce enough of either clean water
or nutritious and healthy food
that is enough for our current population.
And think of this,
that if we were simply to use
today's agricultural technologies,
to feed 10 billion people what
require additional farmland
equal to the landmass of
South America and Africa.
Clearly, that is not gonna happen.
So we need to develop technologies
that are gonna produce
the food and the water
that 10 billion people will need.
Now, of course, if we
don't meet the demands
of 10 billion people in
these ways and others,
we can anticipate chaos.
And this problem of a growing populations
rapidly increasing demand
on the planet's sources is not new.
We have heard the story before.
Many of you know so of the
Reverend Thomas Robert Malthus
who in 1798, wrote a fascinating treatise.
He called it "An Essay on
the Principle of Population".
He did a brilliant demographic study.
He was a great demographer.
And he looked at Britain and Europe
and he made the observation
that at that time,
at the end of the 18th century,
the rate of population growth was faster
than the rate of increase in
agricultural productivity.
And I can tell you, don't
need to know any higher math
to understand that this is
a recipe for catastrophe.
Malthus did a demographic
study over history
and he showed that there had been cycles
of population rise and fall.
And the periods of population
rise always ended in tears.
War, famine, pestilence.
And this problem of rising population
faster than rising resources
has come to be known as
a Malthusian dilemma.
So, Malthus in 1798 was
sounding a warning cry.
Watch out, the end is
near, we're about to enter
another one of these catastrophic periods.
But guess what?
At that time, he was wrong.
There was not catastrophe over the horizon
and he was wrong because new technologies
averted the predicted disaster.
What were the new technologies?
Among them were the application
of four-field crop rotation
by farmers in Britain, thereby,
increasing the productivity
of their crops.
And a marvelous new technology
that was one of the
most important products
of those seafaring explorers
who were going across the seas
around the world.
And while, when I read about them
when I was in fourth grade,
they were in search of gold and tobacco
and spices and jewels and
all kinds of exciting things.
But actually, they came upon something
that was even more important in commerce
and that was islands that
were inhabited only by birds
and were essentially huge reservoirs,
enormous piles of guano, bird poo.
Well, guano is an excellent fertilizer
and they're developed a very
robust trade in fertilizer,
I will call it for this
group to be nice about it,
around the world that really accelerated
the rate of crop productivity.
And contrary to Malthus's prediction,
people in Britain didn't starve.
They became well-fed and
actually, population grew.
And what I often reflect
on is it was just in time
for the workforce that was needed
for the industrial revolution.
Now, today, we are facing, once again,
a Malthusian dilemma.
And today, I would offer the possibility
of using this same kind of solution.
We need to invent our way out but can we?
Can we defeat Malthus again?
How do we chart a course
to a better future?
Now, I didn't appreciate this, of course,
until I joined the Rick Levin team
but one of the central responsibilities
of every university president
is to imagine what will be
needed to solve the problems,
not of today, but of the distant future.
And I don't know about all of you
but my crystal ball gets pretty
fuzzy about five years out
and I needed to come up
with a way to think about
what that future might possibly be
that didn't require this
lousy crystal ball that I had.
So, the strategy to imagining
the future that I adopted
was I thought if I could
understand the future
we're living in today and how we got here,
perhaps, that would give
me a path to understanding
what the future we could might anticipate
being living in tomorrow.
So, let's just start by what is the future
we're living in today.
Does anyone have one of
these in this audience?
Of course, we all do.
These amazing products,
these digital products, these cell phones
that every one of us carries
around in our purse or pocket
represent the major technology
story of the 20th century.
It is the Digital Revolution.
I'm gonna divide my observations
today into three parts.
First, I'm gonna talk about how did we get
to the digitally enabled
world that we live in today.
I'm gonna make the case
that digital technologies
today are a product
of the convergence of
physics with engineering,
which I'll convergence 1.0.
I'm gonna explain the
history of the digital world
and say history of discovery
to marketplace technologies.
And then the second part,
I'm gonna offer a view of
tomorrow's likely future.
Tomorrow's transformational technologies
and where they're gonna come from.
And just the other preview,
we are on the cusp of a new convergence.
Convergence 2.0 of
biology with engineering.
It's already in progress
and it's rapidly accelerating
and to my mind, it promises technologies
as impactful and as transformational
as well the digital
technologies we enjoy today.
And lastly, the third part,
I'm gonna close with some thoughts
on what we need to do to
accelerate those technologies
and the bottom line is, as I said before,
to defeat Malthus again,
we need to innovate.
So where did the Digital
Revolution come from?
The Digital Revolution
is a product of 19th century physics.
Curiosity-driven, fundamental discovery
and fundamental discovery, we
know well in the university
is investigations without any
practical application in mind.
So let me just let's go
over a bit of history
that's likely familiar to many of you.
On the left, I'm showing a
drawing of Michael Faraday.
Michael Faraday was
probably one of the world's
greatest investigators of
the behavior of physics.
He studied electromagnetism
and other physical forces
and as I said, he was
studying the behavior
of these physical properties,
not the nature of electricity
or electromagnetism.
He didn't know what the forces were
that were giving rise to these,
the properties he was studying.
And it wasn't until J.J.
Thompson shown on the right,
discovered it'd be electron in 1897
that we began to have an idea
of what those forces were
behind Faraday's observations.
And it wasn't, of course,
Faraday alone or Thompson alone,
there was a whole group of people
who were busy just had to understand
how these things worked.
With the elucidation the
electron, the proton, the neutron,
X-rays and other forces,
we got into our hands, a parts
list of the physical world.
Electrons are a fantastically useful part
and one of the important parts
of the physical parts list,
physical world's parts list.
Of course, my dear friends, the engineers
like nothing better than a parts list
and engineers picked up
those physical world parts
and turn them into practical applications.
The electronics industry was born
and in that and industry,
we got vacuum tubes and transistors,
which enabled any number of
new kinds of technologies.
Broadcast radio and television,
long distance telephony
and a whole universe of new technologies.
And then the electronics industry
has had some very useful progeny.
the computer and information industries.
This is the story of discovery
leading to industrial products,
which have fueled
economic and jobs growth.
It has been very productive,
not just in terms of these
digital technologies used today
but in terms of bettering
the lives of many.
Now, the electronics
industry was coming along
at a reasonable pace but
frankly, a little sleepily
and invariably,
technology's most powerful catalyst
is unfortunately, war.
Napoleon recognized this when in 1805,
he repurposed Ecole Polytechnique
into a military academy.
He understood that to wage the wars,
he was waging and about
to wage successfully,
he needed to have the best
technology on the planet
and so did we.
So during World War II, the United States
and all the other nations
invested massively in technology.
It's a fantastic story and of course,
I can't dig into enormous detail
but our nation's massive World
War II investments in R&D
led to technology miracles
and ultimately, won the war.
Now, there's a whole list of technologies
that came out of World War
II would include radar.
Many consider radar to be
the war-winning technology.
Sonar, the atomic bomb,
certainly, the war-ending technology.
But in addition, the foundations
of computing relayed,
the foundations of GPS and the Internet,
we're all part of this
incredible technology
and push for World War II.
The man who led this
effort was Vannevar Bush
who had been dean of engineering at MIT
and then president of Carnegie.
So it was he who organized
this incredible effort.
Now, as the war was drawing to a close,
President Roosevelt, FDR, turned to Bush
and asked Bush to prepare a post-war plan.
Vannevar did so and the plan,
which was published in a fantastic,
just amazing treatise
called "Science, the Endless Frontier".
Put forward the thesis, that briefly,
that the lessons learned
in the wartime application of science
can be profitably applied in peace.
This was incredibly different
and startlingly counterintuitive.
After prosecuting a war
successfully, a nation is bankrupt.
They've been drowning all these debt.
And the biggest force after
a war is to reduce the debt
and pull back on expenditures
and Bush was advocating
exactly the opposite.
Bush advocated that rather than pull back,
we should double down
on those investments.
In "Science, Endless Frontier"
he lays out all the different ways
these investments should be placed.
A powerful blueprint for
America's second half
of the 20th century.
It was a blueprint for
economic, industrial
and sociological expansion.
He advocated for federal investments,
not just in research but in education.
You all know about the GI Bill
which provided education for returning GIs
who many of whom had come off the farm.
But to come back and get an education,
college or community colleges,
there was money for
mortgages and much more.
He described a plan to
accomplish these efforts.
Essentially, he laid out all of the levers
necessary to drive technological
and economic progress.
And his plan would set the foundation
of the 20th century's most
transformational technologies
and industries including
the computer and information
and aerospace, biomedical industries
and everything that the
United States produced
in the second half of the 20th century.
However, his supporter, FDR died.
And FDR his successors
were not as enthusiastic
as building further debt.
And so, they were following
Bush's plan, I would say,
a little bit more slowly
than Bush or FDR would have.
So the post-war effort
got off to a slow start
until Sputnik.
1957, the Russians beat the United States
into space with Sputnik.
And I recall this as it's
though were yesterday,
that blinking light of Sputnik
traveling across the sky
cast a very dark shadow
across this nation.
And in response, President Kennedy
announced a race to the moon.
And Kennedy gave any
number of speeches about
that quite inspirational
and this is a quotation
from a speech he gave at Rice University.
And I wanna move this in a
direction beyond the technology.
He says, "We choose to go
to the moon in this decade
and do the other things,
not because they're easy,
but because they're hard
and because that goal
will serve to organize
and measure the best of
our energies and skills."
And this shared ambition,
this national goal
that Kennedy called out
drove both national security
and economic and jobs growth.
It was a far-reaching
catalyst for technology,
for education and for industry.
A certain national ambition reaches
well-beyond those directly
engaged in the effort.
I wanna offer one example.
Now, people often ask me
how I got into science
and how I got from science
to the presidency of MIT.
Well, the simple answer is that I grew up
under the shadow of Sputnik.
This is me with my three sisters
and I was very fortunate,
we were all very fortunate
in having parents who basically told us
that we could do anything that we wanted.
We just had to have the ambition
and the willingness to work hard.
So for me then, and for my generation,
growing up under the shadow
spot wasn't the shadow of fear,
it was the bright beacon of inspiration.
What science could bring the world
without any boundaries in
terms of what I could study
whether it was science
or history or English.
I heard President Kennedy's
call to action and I echoed it
by articulating the call for
science in the new economy
and found my calling.
Now, this next slide is
a little embarrassing
but I had to include it
to demonstrate what power
a national ambition has
even on second grade kids.
So this is an essay, an illustrated essay.
It's a challenge to call it illustrated
because I wasn't a good illustrator
and it's a little embarrassing
to share with you.
I wasn't that good of drawing
or you can see, at spelling
or at grammar or penmanship
and I would admit readily
that all those deficits remained with me.
However, even as a second grader,
I got caught up in the enthusiasm
of this national ambition.
That Sputnik, that bright beacon through,
not just me, but a whole
generation of children,
fueled our national and soon
to be international ambition.
So whether you're
directly involved or not,
you experience a sense of reflected glory
and a sense of everyone
working toward an ambition
that's greater than your own.
So, the other thing I
wanna call out from this
is the last sentence.
I don't know how I knew this.
I was in second grade that
you could figure things out
maybe figure out how to go to the moon
but it would be fun.
So I recognized even then the magnificent
and exciting paradox that you
can pursue your personal dream
and serve others.
And it is, in many ways,
a description of the power
of shared ambition.
So, the Great War and
then great shared ambition
and Cold War fueled the most
powerful transformation current
of the 20th century.
I'm illustrating here just a few products
of the convergence of
physics with engineering,
convergence 1.0.
Great policy, important investments
drove technology development
that fuels economic growth
and these technologies permeate
every nook and cranny of our lives.
So the question is what's next?
How do we defeat Malthus this time?
Where will the future come from?
And as I mentioned earlier,
there's another convergence
that builds on this
20th century convergence
of physics with engineering
adding biology into it.
But biology, as late as 1950,
needed several revolutions of its own
in order to participate.
Biology didn't have a parts list.
So the first revolution in biology
that delivered the parts list
was the revolution of molecular biology.
Molecular biology transformed the way
we thought about biology.
It developed a biology parts list
starting with the description
of the structure of DNA
and then the understanding that the code,
the vocabulary of DNA, the words of DNA
were translated into an
intermediary molecule called RNA.
And that RNA then was the molecule
that gave the directions
to construct proteins.
There are many, many proteins,
each very specific to a particular cell
or tissue or organism but
having these concepts in hand
gave biology the parts list it needed.
Of course, we came to understand that DNA
was the substance of heredity
and we could identify
particular DNA segments
that's sometimes were
responsible for a disease.
We can now construct molecules
that intervened diseases
by intervening at the level
of DNA or RNA or protein.
It has been an extraordinarily productive
set of discoveries, this parts
list of the biological world.
Now, molecular biology
gave us the possibility
to study genes one by one.
Incredible insights but we
needed another revolution
in a sense, industrialized biology
and that second molecular
biology revolution is genomics.
I'm showing here a graph that illustrates
the declining cost of
sequencing a human genome.
That is perhaps the most
important tool that we have
in studying biology and applying biology
to other activities.
I'm competing the cost of
the genome in the red line
against Moore's law which is
the incredibly rapid increase
in the number of transistors
that can fit on a computer chip,
which is a technological
marvel in and of itself
but the declining cost of a human genome,
at least as I here, is even more amazing.
So the first human genome
came out of the human the genome project,
which was roughly between 1984 and 2003,
took about 10 years to
sequence the first human genome
and depending on how you measure it,
it costs between 100 and $150
million to sequence a genome.
This declining costs and increasing speed
in sequencing a human genome,
today, my colleagues
across the street from me
at the Broad Institute tell me
that they can sequence the
human genome, not in 10 years,
in six minutes and the
cost of that sequencing
is well less than $1,000 a genome.
An extraordinary advance.
The point is that having the understanding
of the components of molecular
biology and genomics,
we now have a biology parts list.
And when I arrived at MIT,
I discovered that my marvelous
friends, the engineers,
were picking up this new parts list
and using it to build new technologies
in ways that are entirely transformative
and quite remarkable.
So, the third the revolution
that I'm gonna talk about
is, of course, is the convergence
of biology with engineering,
convergence 2.0,
and there are a number
of examples in the book.
For today, I'm just gonna talk about two.
I'm gonna give you an
example from healthcare,
an example from energy.
But the point of my book and
the point of today's lecture
is that these new technologies
are emerging all around you
and if I can just give you the translation
that allows you to understand
that this convergence 2.0
is happening all around,
you will see examples.
You'll see examples when
you pick up a newspaper
when you run into any description
of the science of today.
So, let's get started.
The first example comes from
my colleague, Sangeeta Bhatia,
and I'm gonna be a little
briefer 'cause I see we're,
I don't wanna run over,
I wanna give you plenty
of time for questions.
So Sangeeta Bhatia is a nanotechnologist,
she's an engineer, she's also an MD
and she's tackled a problem of detection.
Now, you'll recall that we talked
about how much money we spend on disease
and if we use cancer as an example
of just the inefficiency of our system,
if you have cancer, well,
actually, let's just back up.
What's the best way of battling cancer?
The best way is not to get it
and if you use the tools that we have,
stop smoking, if you use sunscreen,
I'm as guilty as anyone
else in not using sunscreen
as often as I should,
if you get the vaccines
against the viruses
that we know to cause cancer,
all of that will reduce
the amount of cancer
in our population and indeed,
the cessation of smoking
or the reduction in smoking
has had a dramatic effect on
the incidence of lung cancer.
However, even if you did
everything we know today
for many cancer, people still get cancer
and the second best approach
for cancer is early detection.
Cancer is a disease for
some one cell, then two,
then four, then eight, these cells divide
and the earlier you catch cancer,
the earlier you can detect and remove
a cancerous set of cells,
the better chance you have at a cure.
However, our current technologies,
while they're much better
than they were before
are still often insufficient
to detect a cancer
at a small enough size
or a cancer before it's moved
from its tissue of origin
to others before it's metastasized,
which makes it a very
difficult disease to treat.
So Sangeeta has decided to tackle this
using the genius of biology.
On the right side of the slide,
and I didn't put my pointer up.
Let me see if I can put my pointer up.
Yeah, hold on, one second.
Let's see.
I hope you can see that.
On the right side of the
slide, this turquoise center,
this is a nanoparticle,
about 15 nanometers in size,
that Sangeeta has
decorated with a very short
segment of protein and
that's shown in this gold
with a little turquoise marker part
of that protein on the end.
Every cell, every tissue
has its own proteins
and its own proteins
that cut other proteins
and those are called enzymes.
Tissue-specific or
disease-specific enzymes
and that's illustrated
by this little Pac-Man,
this gold Pac-Man character
which represents a cancer enzyme.
Now, with this nanoparticle
that Sangeeta has designed,
the idea is that if someone
is suspected of having cancer,
they get injected with a nanoparticle
and if they don't have cancer,
it remains intact and
passes out of the body
like other waste material.
However, if cancer is
present and these enzymes,
these cancer enzymes are present,
these cancer enzymes will clip
these little protein tethers,
these little peptide tethers,
releasing the signal part of that protein,
these little turquoise loops.
Sangeeta has engineered
these loops to be very small.
Small enough that they can find their way
back into the bloodstream
and once they're back in the bloodstream,
they are so small that the kidney
thinks their waste products
and passes them into the urine.
So if you have cancer and
you were to get this test,
we could gather your urine and
look where these turquoise,
they're not turquoise in real
experiment but marker proteins
and because the urine
normally has a very, very low background
of protein or any contaminant,
you get a very profound signal to noise.
Sangeeta starting to cut started a company
called Glympse Bio to bring
this technology to the market
and they are currently in clinical trials.
In their animal models,
this enzyme-mediated detection technology
can detect tumors when
they are 1/10 the size
of current best in
class detection methods.
If we could detect cancer
when they're 1/10 of the size,
we would have a very great
advantage on beating it.
So these are the kinds of technologies
that come out of a nanotechnologist lab
but again, a nanotechnologist,
which builds these little devices,
these nanoparticles using nanotechnology
but uses nature's genius,
the brilliant specificity
and efficiency of our enzymes
to produce a detection technique.
I'm just gonna skip the next slide
and I'll just say very briefly
that this is an intravenous,
a bloodborne detection assay
but Sangeeta has also
established this kind of assay
has an inhaled assay to
detect lung diseases.
For example, COVID.
And here, the nanoparticles are inhaled.
If you have the disease, the
little marker proteins here,
they're in orange that cleaved
off and you exhale them
which can be detected with a breathalyzer.
The reason that this is for me,
such a compelling direction
in such an impellingly important
concept of possibilities
that we desperately need.
I gave the example for cancer
but frankly, for me, one
of the most painful parts
of watching COVID go
through our populations
over the last year was
the lack of diagnostics.
We have a diagnostics
deficit in the country
that's bad for cancer and it's terrible
in the case of the pandemic.
We need better diagnostics that
we can detect disease early
as I've described, accurately, quickly.
You should be able to understand
whether you have COVID
or not within 15 minutes
of walking into your provider's office,
not after two days that are inexpensive,
that are sensitive and that
can perform millions of tests.
We don't have it yet and I'm hoping
that coming out of COVID,
we may actually get ourselves
organized around it.
The next example I'm gonna give
is from another colleague
at the Koch Institute,
Angela Belcher.
Angie is a materials engineer
and in this picture on the left,
that's Angie and in her hand,
she's holding an abalone shell.
The abalone shell is filled
with coin cells batteries
and they look like the coin cell batteries
that you might use to
change for your remote
or any one of your small
electronic devices.
However, these just look like
those coin cell batteries
because they're filled
with a new kind of battery
that Angie has developed and are batteries
that are made by nature.
When Angie was a student
at UC Santa Barbara,
she used to walk along the ocean's edge,
loved the ocean's edge
but what she really loved
were these abalone shells
because she reasoned
that abalone, a sea creature,
picks off the materials from
the sea it lives in around it
and built an abalone shell which
is the technology it needs.
It's strong, it's
lightweight and best of all,
when the abalone dies, an
abalone shell disintegrates
into its component parts
so that the next abalone
can build its shell or
another sea creature
can use those components.
And Angie thought,
you know, if abalone can
build the technology they need
without contaminant their
world, why can't we?
So Angie's work is devoted
to using nature's tools
to build technologies that are better.
And as I described at the beginning,
we have an enormous energy problem
and that's gonna get much worse.
And we have to figure
out how to address it.
Now, people are enthusiastic
about alternative energy.
I love wind I love solar too
but the rate limiting technology
for getting out of our energy dilemma,
frankly, is not bigger or wind turbines
or larger solar farms.
The problem, the rate limiting technology
is energy storage, batteries.
We've made a lot of improvement
in battery technology
but frankly, state-of-the-art
lithium-ion batteries
are not the end of the story for us.
They can't be.
In order to manufacture
lithium-ion batteries,
you need an enormous amount of heat.
It's a very, very intensive heat process
so it consumes a lot of energy
and there are a lot of toxic byproducts.
So unless we figure out
how to build batteries
more sustainably, we are
not gonna get very far
with the best alternative
energy strategies
that we can imagine.
So Angie has done a number of things
but for the battery application,
she has used a small bacteriophage,
a virus that infects
bacteria and it showed here,
it's called the M13 virus.
And she described that she's
caused nature to evolve faster.
Viruses normally bind living organisms,
material from living
cells and Angie's question
is could she persuade these M13 viruses
to bind battery materials?
Inorganic materials, and
indeed, that's what she's done.
I'm just gonna show you a
slide just to illustrate
how these batteries are built.
So here, over on the left is an M13.
You see it's quite small,
less than 10 nanometers across
and it has a very the
repetitive structure.
So there are proteins called
p8 that forms the core.
The tuft of these viruses
formed by a protein called p3
and she has modified the p3 proteins
so that they bind
single-walled carbon nanotubes,
which are very good
conductors of electricity
or in some cases, cobalt,
magnesium, lithium,
the components for batteries.
Once these viruses have been modified,
they're kind of crystalline
so they pack together very
closely the way crystals do
and then she uses them to build cathodes.
She also, this case, in this illustration,
the anode is a lithium foil
but she's also used virus-built anodes.
She packs them together into
these coin cell battery cases
and they looked just
like any old coin cell
but they're not because
they're built from nature.
Most importantly, her battery
manufacturing technology
builds these batteries at room temperature
without any toxic byproducts.
If we could build the batteries we need
using Angie's technology,
we would have a chance
to get out of our dilemma of
having insufficient energy.
So, two examples that I think
are just fabulous
illustrations of using nature
to build better.
So, now, these convergence
things are easy to describe
but they are hard to do.
Why is it hard to implement
and accelerate convergence?
The first is the innovator's dilemma.
If we think about our university
as just in terms of making it possible
for people to talk across disciplines,
our university worked pretty darn well.
And if you're gonna be a chemist,
it's important that you learn chemistry,
probably more important
than you learn chemistry
than you understand how
semiconductors work.
However, this is a problem
in terms of advancing
into our next world
and the challenges across
disciplines makes sense.
Disciplines use different languages,
they use different approaches
and of course, there're
any number of structures,
institutional structures
that make it difficult
for people to communicate
across disciplines
and our funding agencies are siloed.
This, to me, has been a really
very, very difficult problem.
Fabulous for Vannevar Bush and have said
let's set up these funding agencies
but the fact is that the
National Institutes of Health
has done a fabulous job at
funding biology and biomedicine,
the NSF has done a fabulous job
at funding computer
science and engineering
and the Department of Energy
has done a fabulous
job at funding physics.
Just the question is how
do you provide funding
for activities that cross disciplines?
Once in a while, we've
gotten this together.
There was a National
Nanotechnology Initiative
that brought together
four different agencies
and really propelled the United
States from being a laggard
to a leader in nanotechnology.
The current brain project
also brings together
many different agencies
to solve the some of the
really daunting problems
of decoding the brain.
But the fact is those are exceptions,
they're not the rule
and we need to be able
to do cross disciplinary funding and work
without inventing a new
process to do so every time.
I'm gonna give you just one example
and I'll go through
this relatively quickly
of one of our convergence efforts at MIT.
This is the Koch Institute for
Integrative Cancer Research.
We put it together in 2007,
the building was done in 2011
and I have to say there are several things
that make this work.
The first is that everyone in the building
shares the ambition to accelerate
progress against cancer.
And the second is that
there is protected space.
All of the faculty in the Koch Institute
have their faculty appointments
in their departments.
In biology, in mechanical engineering,
in the department of material
sciences and engineering
and they just cohabitate
for their research
so we didn't have to
change the academic process
of faculty appointments.
That really allowed us to accelerate.
And the third element that is
absolutely critical success
is we had seed funding
outside of standard funding practices.
What do I mean?
Private philanthropy, enormous generosity
by a number of philanthropists
that allowed us to get started and prove
what we said we were gonna do which then
allowed us to get funding for this
from the standard agencies.
But that was absolutely essential.
And we built this building
and established this Institute
with the determination
that we were going to foster collaboration
and we engineered with four
layers of collaboration.
Up here in the top left,
chosen original floor plan
of one of the floors of the building.
All the floors are mixed.
With engineering and biology,
we want to encourage
people to talk together
and this was the early plan and now,
as faculty have left and
new faculty have come,
it's actually more integrated
that you don't have a biology half
and engineering half of a floor.
Importantly, the building
has one set of stairs,
one set of elevators,
one set of restrooms,
one cafe so wherever you go,
you're likely to run into someone
who comes from the other
side of the equation
and that's been enormously helpful.
We situated the Koch Institute
among a number of other disciplines.
Obviously, next to the biology building,
the Stata Center is the home
of electrical engineering,
computer science,
right across the street
are the Broad Institute and
the Whitehead Institute,
chemical engineering is here,
chemistry is right here.
It makes it very easy as
you crossed this courtyard,
again, to run into people
who aren't exactly like you
and easy to start those conversations
that might otherwise be difficult.
You all are certainly aware that MIT
does not have a medical
school or a hospital.
This is the third layer of collaboration.
We have to establish collaboration
with our clinical partners.
Mass General Hospital,
here, down here,
Dana-Farber/Brigham and Women's,
Children's Hospital.
We have great hospitals in
our region, just not at MIT,
and we have something
called the bridge project
that brings together clinicians
with a clinical awareness
and understanding of cancer
along with our biologists and engineers.
And of course, I would be telling you
only part of the story
if I didn't remind you
that MIT, which are these
buildings shown in red
are embedded in the Kendall
Square Innovation District.
My colleague, the Nobel
Prize winner, Phil Sharp,
often says that technology
travels on two feet and it does.
And so, it is to say
we've lowered the barriers
for translating great discoveries
into marketplace lifesaving
products by where we sit
because if your office is
here in the Koch Institute,
you don't have to walk too far to talk
to venture capitalists and
people in the industry community.
So, does it work?
This is just one way you measure it.
Obviously, there are more
grants and more publications
but because we were
interested in implementation,
we had kept very close
track of the companies
that have started out
in the Koch Institute.
And you can see back here
when we started the
Koch Institute in 2007,
a few companies were being started
and we now have more than 100 companies
that have been founded have
worked at the Koch Institute.
Among those companies,
at least 30 of them now
have products in clinical trials.
So we feel that we're really delivering
on our ambition to accelerate
progress against cancer.
So, what is convergence 2.0 good for?
I would say just about anything.
And I've given some examples here
and we talked about some of the challenges
of the 21st century and the
importance of tackling them
in a way that will not
just solve these problems
but in the best of scenarios,
also drive the kind of
industrial and economic growth
that we enjoyed in the second
half of the 20th century.
So, the answer to the Malthusian dilemma,
of course, is more innovation.
But we have to invest massively
in innovation for it to work
and that is always suspect.
Research is inefficient,
you never know where it's
going when you embark on it
and since the early part of the,
second half of the 20th century
where we got onto the Vannevar Bush plan,
we have invested
significant federal funds.
They have to be federal funds
because the process of
innovation is just too slow
for a company to invest
in this kind of work.
They will invest later on when an idea
is beginning to end mature
but not at the outset
and this is the responsibility
of the federal government.
However, it is always doubted.
This is a story that may be apocryphal.
Apparently, the then equivalent
secretary of the treasury,
the Chancellor of the
Exchequer, William Gladstone,
asked Faraday why he was bothering to do
his kind of bumbling
around in the laboratory.
What was the worth of it?
And Faraday has reported to have replied,
"Why sir, there's every probability
that you will soon be able to tax it."
And indeed, when I bought my last iPhone,
I did pay some tax on that.
It is the route to economic
and industrial progress
but we have to feel it
from the very beginning.
So, Bob Solow, an MIT
economist did the great study
that showed that over
50% of economic growth
since World War II is due to technology,
not the standard
components of the economy.
A very important study that
demonstrated the real product
how much a nation can gain
by that investing in the
raw material of innovation.
So, how are we doing?
This is a diagram showing in red
are investments since 1953 in R&D.
I'm showing both the federal funds
and also business funds in blue
and I just wanna remind you
that the business funding side
is more on the development side
of the research and development, R&D side
but it's the research, the
fundamental research side
that the federal government
has been responsible for.
This graph shows it
as a kind of a national
commitment to this effort
and by demonstrating the percent of GDP.
We got started in 50s, reached
the peak in the mid 1960s
and have then tailed off.
This graph doesn't go all
the way to the present day
but today, it's about 0.7 or 0.8% of GDP
that goes into this kind of
investment in our future.
And you can say well,
it's still a lot of money
and it is a lot of money.
Of course, won't surprise you
that I think never enough money
for this particular effort.
And after World War II, we
were in this game by ourselves.
The countries that could have competed
were putting all the money they had
into rebuilding their cities
and their countrysides
that had been decimated during the war.
United States was in a
very different place.
We had the, let's say, the luxury
of investing in our future
and the world's future.
But that's no longer the case.
There's a lot of competition out there
and you can say that's
a good thing and it is.
Here are the numbers
from a number of countries
around the world.
And you can see already that
South Korea, Japan and Germany
invest a greater percentage
of their GDP in research.
The line I worry about a lot, of course,
is this purple line, China.
And I don't know whether this purple line
has yet crossed the red line.
My guess is it will have
already done so last month
or if it hasn't already done so,
it'll be next month or next year.
The way the United States
has managed our technology
and come to the position that we have
through the 20th century is not a secret.
It's there for all the world to see
and all the world is,
as rapidly as they can,
following our pattern.
So if we wanna be a player,
a major player going forward,
we have to continue to
make these investments.
So, there are things
about our federal policy
that, I think, are essential
to building this incredibly
important resource
for the country.
We need to have sustained
federal investments
in basic research.
I paid attention to this, of course,
as soon as I started my own
lab where there were rich years
or more generous years and poor years
in terms of getting federal
grants to do our research
and nothing could be more debilitating
to a young investigator
than not to be able
to get the funding to
support her or his research
because of the vagaries in funding.
Funding needs to be consistent.
Very important for this convergence 2.0
and for whatever
convergence 3.0 is gonna be
is that we have flexible funds available
for cross agency collaborations
to fund the kind of work
that I've described today
and then I have in my book.
Importantly, when an interesting
idea gets out of the lab
and is ready to go to the marketplace,
we need policies
that better support
investments in innovation.
We do have a robust investment mechanism
in the United States but I would say
we could do more to encourage individuals
and investors to put their
money into this kind of work.
And it may sound weird coming from MIT
where we're known fairly
well for our ability
to tech to transfer
technology from the lab
to the marketplace but even in MIT,
I think we can do a better
job of making it easier,
making it faster
'cause these industry
university collaborations
are critically important
to get across the gap
between a laboratory discovery
and a marketplace technology
that's gonna save a life.
So, I've described you the
products of the convergence
or some of the products.
At least, the thesis
behind convergence 2.0
which, I think, will
be the technology story
of the 21st century.
It's a story of fundamental research
that moves to applications
that move to new businesses
and new industries.
And you know, we simply
must defeat Malthus again.
But my very greatest hope
is that defeat of Malthus,
I hope, will come not
from the threat of war
but by the promise of peace.
So my book gives you a front row seat
on some of the most amazing,
almost science fiction technologies
coming out of labs right now.
As I said, it's written
for a general audience
and I just hope everyone
can enjoy the excitement
of this generation's technology revolution
and to understand it and I hope you will.
Thanks and I'll take some questions now.
- Thank you so much, Susan,
for sharing your vision
and I am delighted that our president,
president of Yale, Peter Salovey,
a former friend and colleague of yours
would love to ask the first question.
So, Peter.
- Hey, Peter.
- While that's happening,
it's great to see you, Susan,
and Priya, thank you for hosting us
and for calling on me to
ask the first question.
That's very nice of you.
Tamar, that was a great introduction.
And Rich and Barbara Franke,
thank you so much for enabling all of this
and so much else that you do for Yale.
Just before I ask the question,
it's great to see about
100 people with us today
and one thing I did want to acknowledge
is that Susan really is my
mentor as an administrator.
And back in January of 2003,
it's really December 2002,
Rick Levin asked me to be
dean of the graduate school
when Susan moved over
to the provost's office
and he gave me about a half
a day to think about it
and about
a week to get trained up and start
and Susan was always someone
who was kind of a role model
and then who tutored me
during that holiday break
and got me tuned up to become a dean.
And I had no idea where that
was going to lead either
and at the time, I just wanted to see
if I could get through January 2003
without doing something foolish and,
but Susan was a great, great teacher
in this other area of university life
and I'm very thankful for that.
We're trying here at Yale to do
some of the things that you have suggested
that we do in order to create convergence
and produce change in the world.
We're also co-locating faculty
across disciplinary boundaries.
So, in the humanities,
you could see people
coming together in our new quadrangle
and in the Woodside Institute
at 100 College Street,
you can see neuroscientists
and psychologists
and computer scientists
and some data science all converging.
What used to be called Kline Biology Tower
is now the Klein Tower of
data science, astronomy,
mathematics, right?
So we're doing all this
co-location and certainly,
where we're trying to engage
philanthropists as you suggest
and we're doing more
industrial collaborations
with industry as you suggest.
And particularly for Yale, that was a new,
has been a bit more of a new adventure
and has been a successful one.
So my question is should we go further?
I'm not suggesting this seriously
so nobody who's watching should panic
but as a thought experiment,
break down the disciplinary
barriers completely,
not have not have departments anymore,
maybe not even have schools,
admit people to PhD programs in science
or humanities or social science.
There's one university
out on the West Coast
where faculty move between industry
and the university with
almost no barriers.
So one year there at Google,
one year they're at Stanford,
doesn't seem to matter.
And should we really go further?
Should we?
I think co-location is great.
I think raising money is important
and industrial collaboration
has, I think, created new avenues.
But should we, as Yale, or we as academia,
however you want to answer it,
should we go should we go even further?
- Yeah, that's a great question, Peter,
and it's one obviously
that I've gotten often.
And it may surprise,
probably not you, but others
that I actually, people would ask me,
well, don't we need to change departments?
And I wouldn't even know how to begin
to think about changing departments.
And people need an intellectual home
and people need to know something, right?
All of this is possible because the people
who are participating are deeply rooted
in a discipline and they know
what that discipline brings them.
And the question is how do
you provide the flexibility
so that you can have the conversations
with people from a different discipline
to come up with a new idea?
So, I often say, I don't
know what the names
of huge departments would be
but we need more flexibility.
And I'll tell you, Peter,
you've probably seen this also.
The students, the next generation
are lunatics about this.
So they are, even with
the time I first arrived
at MIT in 2004 and I would,
when the freshmen arrive,
you do the same thing wander around campus
and start up conversations
with our new members of our community
and I said, "What do you
think you might wanna do?"
And a huge fraction said,
"Oh, I wanna do biomedical
engineering," or I want to,
and that has only increased.
One of the things that we've done at MIT
that I think is good for both
the faculty and the students
is that when I arrived,
the undergraduate majors
were disciplinary.
And if you wanted to add
something on, you could
but the students' schedules
are already pretty packed
and it was doable but not easy.
And now, we have a whole
array of hybrid majors.
So you can major in biology
and computer science.
You can major in your
biology and computer science.
You can major in, there are a
number of these hybrid majors
and it's important
because, for two reasons.
One is the students wanna do it
but the other reason it's
important is it gives our faculty
a chance to pioneer these new fields
because you know well that
it really is in architecting
our majors or requirements
that we architect a field.
That's the way we pioneer fields.
And so, I think that I wouldn't abandon
all of the organization
because people like,
you're a psychologist,
you know better than I
how much good comes out of
a more intimate community
when that community is
situated in a candy store
of other opportunities.
So I'm not a fan of letting
everyone lose to self-associate
but I am a fan of what I often describe
as turning footpaths into super highways.
You'll figure out how
to make the connection
with a physicist do you wanna talk to
for your experiments, right?
And once you've kind
of bushwhacked your way
between disciplines,
why should the next
person have to go through
that same bushwhacking process?
And so putting in place the,
as I said, the super highways
rather than just the footpaths,
I think is a way of creating this
and I'm a really a huge believer,
I have a lot of confidence
in bringing our students
into this reinvention of the future
by giving them the
opportunities to (chuckles),
as I collect my...
Be the plasmids.
So the plasmids is are
these genetic elements
that move knowledge from
one cell to another.
And so the students really
are in a university,
the information carrier carriers,
that are the real people who are doing
the bridging of disciplines.
- Thank you, Susan.
It's so good to see you.
- [Susan] It's great to see you, Peter.
- Thank you so much, Susan.
And, I think, from your talk
we could see the imprint
that you have left on the MIT campus.
As an alum, I have seen the
transformation is incredible.
I really hope you can come
to Yale, to our campus,
and to see how things are changing
in the geography and in terms
of these intellectual connections.
So we have a lot of questions
and I'm really tempted
to ask you one myself before I launch.
And that is you discussed
this a little bit in your book
and I was curious about your views.
So there's been talk
about for by economists
like Mariana Mazzucato and others
who've talked about how
maybe the federal government
and federal funding
for blue skies research
should have some incentivized way
of returning some money
back to the government
so that you can grow this blue skies fund
from the federal side always.
So for example, a simple
example that she often cites
is Google that came out of
the NSS libraries project,
if only they had said 0.001%,
if your idea gets monetized
comes back for blue skies research.
So I was very curious
whether what your views were
on other than philanthropy
and industrial partnerships,
whether you felt that
the federal government
had a larger role to play in fostering
this new kind of innovation.
- Yeah, Priya, thanks for that question
and you've touched on something
that I think is really key
and most people don't appreciate,
which is it is a nation that wants
to be part of the industrial future
has to invest in the
infrastructure, right?
In the ground floor
because the ground floor,
you don't know where it's
going, you have to invest
and you have to do it wisely.
Vannevar Bush was so brilliant
in saying that we have to
provide federal funds for that
because no one can afford to invest in it.
You never make enough
money out it directly.
But as you said, there's
a huge amount of money
that's produced and we have to understand
that investing federal funds
in the first steps of this enterprise
is absolutely required.
The idea is you can buy
it from someone else.
That's clearly a fool's errand.
That has not worked
for any nation although
we worry about patenting and copywriting.
People often remind me that United States
didn't have copyright laws
until we started producing enough books
and Britain was furious that, for example,
Charles Dickens books were
published in the United States
were never published in Britain
because they were obviously,
done out outside of copyright.
so I so I think it's
important for us to invest
and I know, I mean obviously,
I've been involved in you've been involved
in telling the story of the critical role
of blue skies research.
But I do believe that, as you say,
that the companies, the
industries that have profited
from that research should be returning
and frankly, they do return
some of those profits back
into the into federal government.
Federal government has to
decide how to use those funds
and of course, there are infinite demands
but I think it's absolutely essential
and I just wish I had
kind of a magic formula
to help people understand
how important it is.
But I think that any nation
that wants to be an
industrial and economic force
has to invest as generously as imaginable
in this kind of effort.
That's why I showed these comparisons
between the United States
and other countries.
It's not a surprise that Germany
and South Korea and Japan
industrial powerhouses are the countries
that are investing more than we are
as as a fraction of GDP, of course.
- Great.
Tamar, if you had a question,
now would be a good time to go
because there's a real pileup.
- There's a whole queue.
I'm happy to pass my
spot on to a colleague.
- Okay, great.
So the first question
was from Justin Zaremby
who said, "It's very
striking when Bell Labs
got rid of its fundamental
physics research
in about 2008 or so.
What would it take for commercial ventures
to explore basic research
alongside applied research
or does the inefficiency of basic research
limited to existing within
university settings solely?"
- Hey, Justin.
Thanks for thanks for joining us today.
I was so happy to see your
name in the list of attendees.
So, you've actually asked
a critical question.
So why was there Bell Labs?
Why was there a GE Research Lab?
It was possible because those companies,
I wouldn't go so far as
to call it a monopoly
but they actually controlled
so much of the industry
that they had the resources
and they were funding,
frankly, not simply their own work
but they had the resources
available to fund it and as,
I'll use a kind word,
as industrial economics
became more efficient,
those kinds of resources
were not available
or claim to be not available
and so we should have very, very few
industrial research labs.
So the story of the Bell Labs
was Bell Labs was, obviously, legendary
for the kind of physics,
fundamental physics research that they did
and you might say this is
something that we could dream of
but the economic structure
doesn't support it.
And what would it require?
It might require a kind
of federal accounting
but how would you measure what research
was really blue sky research
and what research was
really the D side of R&D,
the development research?
And I think it's my guess,
although I haven't been inside,
the companies that are involved
in space exploration now,
I don't know how much fundamental
research is going on there
but my guess is probably not so much.
So I actually, I'm a fan
of the system we have
but I desperately wish that as a nation,
we were as committed to our
future as we are to our present.
- Great, thanks.
The next question is
from James Fairweather
and the question is do
you think that biology
is quickly approaching the same level
of development practice as software?
So it's sort of the
idea of version control,
software-defined vaccines,
patch upgrades of software
to improve performance,
et cetera, et cetera.
If so, how long you reckon before biology
develops the same standards
of interoperability
that accelerated mechanical engineering?
Sort of the standardization, he's saying,
of examples of thread sizes,
dimensioning, et cetera
and in electronics with interfaces
and discreet components and software
with cloud software-defined
infrastructure.
- It's a great question.
So it's the industrialization
of the biology parts list
and that's happening.
It's not so hard to get a
biological piece that you need.
I think one of the, and
I'm speaking about this
as someone who knows very little
about the world of computer science.
One of the remarkable things about biology
is we still are discovering new things.
And so, it's not as
though we have completed
the biology parts list.
It's not as though we
understand all of the pieces
that make a biological organism work.
We are discovering new things every day.
I mean I hesitate to bring
it to the conversation
but CRISPR-Cas9, who would have thought
that this kind of system existed?
And not only have we discovered it
but we also figured out how to deploy it
for any number of uses.
And so I don't know
that this kind of
regularization standardization.
Obviously, the elements themselves
have a structure and a limitation to them.
But I don't know whether we'll have
the kind of standardization
that now exists
or is evolving in the computer industry.
Good question.
- So the next question is from Barry Abel
and he asks, all of this depends
on the brain as a resource,
yet, the brain sciences
have somewhat lag behind,
particularly psychiatry.
Can you speak to the importance
of focusing this convergence
on ways to help brains function better?
- Yeah, it's a great question.
As a neuroscientist, I feel quite humbled
because neuroscience has moved more slowly
than we would have dreamed
and it's another place
where there was a lot yet to be known.
And obviously, I've got a single tool
to increase that knowledge
and it's just increasing
the kind of research we do.
And I think one of the
great disappointments
of biology as it's evolved up to today
is that we have yet to have
the kind of interventions
that would allow for us to tackle
the kinds of really horrible
diseases of the brain.
There's a chapter in
the book about bionics
and I have to say the progress
in developing smart
prosthetics is breathtaking
and the smartest prosthetics of today
are worlds different
from the dumbest prosthetics of yesterday.
However, figuring out how to
regrow connections in the brain
has been quite daunting
but I have confidence
that with more of this kind
of fundamental research,
we'll get someplace but I have to say,
I've just broken the premise.
So the premise is for blue sky researches,
you don't know what you're gonna come upon
and we desperately know what we need
in terms of psychiatry and neurology.
We're just having a hard time
putting the pieces together.
And I would say as
disappointing as that is,
it also points to the fact
that there's so much more
that we need to learn
and so, it's a tough message to hear
and as neuroscientists, we
hear that message every day.
But I think that I can't
even begin to imagine
where we're gonna be in five or 10 years
but the progress has been incredibly rapid
just in terms of how much we understand
about the fundamental structure,
the development of the brain.
- Right, so while we sort out
the next set of questions,
I have one burning question
so I'm gonna sneak it in here.
So, Susan, a lot of what
you've discussed, right?
We are talking about a
highly advanced country,
these technologies that
might provide solutions
primarily aimed at the wealthy.
So, I was curious about how you thought
we could move forward and defeat Malthus
but also envision a more equitable world.
Especially, right now,
even with just the
COVID-19 vaccine rollout
and this is a perfect
situation where the entire,
for the world to be safe,
we all need to be vaccinated
and it's not gonna be enough
just for the wealthy countries
in the West to be vaccinated
given how global we are.
So how do you see this convergence
spreading and radiating out
in a more equitable way?
Because our survival, we all know,
is really bound up with each
other in such an intricate way.
- Yeah, Priya, this is
such an important question
and in the chapter on food and
agriculture, I do touch on it
and one of the things
that is just stunning
is the insufficiency, not
of advanced therapeutics,
but frankly, just food and
water in the developing world
and one of the problems
with water purification
is this just gosh darn expensive.
We're lousy at purifying
water and I offer an example
of something that promises a
completely different approach
to water purification
that could be efficient
and could be economical.
And the same thing with food.
I mean, among, for me,
one of the tragedies
of recent decades is
that there are viruses,
there are plant viruses
that wipe out crops
that the people rely on.
Cassava is a crop that the
most needy people in the world
rely to survive and cassava has a virus
that will wipe out the entire cassava crop
or leave people totally destitute
and there is a way of
genetically modifying cassava,
there's a strain of cassava
that has modified modified
to resist the virus.
And that crop was basically fought against
because of people who are anti-GMO.
And if you can people, why not help them?
And so, it gets caught
up in a lot of politics
and I think that does slow us down
but I think there are so many people
that are absolutely devoted
to moving these kinds of
technologies and discoveries
into the neediest population.
If you look at what's happening
with the vaccine distribution, we're slow.
I mean I have to say vaccine distribution
in Massachusetts has
been ridiculously poor
but there are enough people, I think,
and enough momentum to
actually get the vaccine out
to people all over the world
who desperately need it.
If you think about what we've
done with measles and smallpox
in terms of distributing
these therapeutics
and preventatives, I would
like there to be more
but the awareness of it, I think,
has increased dramatically.
- Thank you so much.
So I think, we are coming up
to 5:30 so I just wanted to end
with one comment that Martin Coburn made
which I thought was very interesting.
He mentions that in 1969,
the Nobel Laureate
physicist, Eugene Wigner
gave a set of lectures at Yale
and the last one was on the
future of quantum mechanics.
And that his thesis was that the future
was actually in biology.
And Willis Lamb who was another
Nobel Laureate physicist
took great exception to that idea,
claiming that there were
no such applications.
So, I guess the future really has shown us
that there are these incredible synergies
and convergences in
completely unexpected places.
So thank you so much, Susan,
for this wonderful talk
and for your vision
and for your leadership
in executing many pieces by demonstration
of how innovation in
the academic landscape
ought to look like
and how it could possibly
change all our lives
for the better.
So thank you so much for coming.
We were hoping to have you come in person
but we just didn't wanna wait any longer.
we already postponed
it from last year and,
but regardless of a talk,
you're always welcome, right?
And Tamar, we would be
thrilled to have you on campus
and come in person to New Haven.
- Priya, Tamar, Peter, thank you so much
for inviting me to be part of this.
Even though virtual, I
can now feel the Yale love
and I'm still part of you, guys.
Looking forward to coming back on campus.
- Yes, and I think, Peter and Tamar,
we're planning up all kinds of parties
and receptions and so on.
So you have a rain check
for a visit to New Haven.
Thank you very much,
everyone, for attending
and I look forward to seeing
you at the next Franke event.